zach frankie on the mound better
right-hander for the houston astros
having himself a pretty good season
record eight and two the
innings at 98 and two thirds 3.52 with
that era
called third strike inside corner at the
knees mancini doesn't like it looked
like a good pitch
zach picks up his first strikeout that
was an extremely good pitch and if zach
continues to
scrape these lines around the strike
zone it is going to be a tough night for
some of these hitters to try and figure
out where that zone is
slowly hit ground ball might have broken
his bat altuve will make the play mount
castle down for the final out of the
inning zach frankie
works through the first one hit and for
thomas zesselman the third start
second consecutive start uh against the
astros so good in the first one
bounced to the left side uria is up with
it altuve down
two two out of the short wind-up and a
breaking ball grounded on a hop to
second valley to a knee picks it throws
it
and gets the out two up two down on the
ground for thomas eshelman here in the
first
fly ball this is in the ballpark mullins
calling
under it and makes the catch stand the
inning
2-2 to tucker with one down here in the
houston second swung on and golfed high
in the air to deep right field
hayes is at the warning track haze in
front of the wall he jumps and he makes
the catch
right at the fence austin hayes with a
leaping catch in front of the right
field fence
may have taken away an extra base hit
may have taken away a home run
either way he records the second out on
a long fly ball
from kyle tucker hayes with his speed he
gets right to the spot and even has a
moment to kind of stop
make a read on the trajectory but that
ball was clearing
by at least two inches over that while
eshelman is absolutely pumped
immediately had his fist in the air
for his right fielder that is definitely
a home run robbery and the only reason i
wasn't sure at first is because hayes
played it so
casually there's austin hayes two down
in the oriole third
no score austin hayes with a two out
single here in the oriole third
hayes takes his lead comes the one two
little looper that'll get down austin
hayes will hold it second
and the orioles have two on with two
down here in the third
so now you get mount castle the plate
two on two down
first pitch swinging line drive left
field in front of bradley
down for a base hit austin hayes around
third he'll score
and the orioles take a one-nothing lead
well three consecutive base hits
estellman against maldonado here in the
third that ball's hit well
could be a new style maldonado off the
wall
the bullpen mckenna plays it off that
bullpen wall and maldi
will get into second with a lead-off
double in the third
[Applause]
and does it again this time off the
first baseman they get the force at
second
first and third one down there you go
there's one on to first the orioles turn
two and get out of the inning
laba got it started ashelman with a big
double play
after the astros put the first two on so
lead off walk for jordan alvarez
and that brings up carlos correa 3-2
pitched
up the middle that will be a base hit
jordan will try to go first to third
he'll get there
carlos correa a single putting runners
on the corners with nobody out in the
fourth
kyle tucker the batter swinging a fly
ball pretty well hit to center field
mullins will go back this will be an
easy tag for jordan alvarez mullen's
throw goes to second
kyle tucker a sac fly the astros on the
board it's now a one-one game
base is juiced while duvet coming to the
plate he's gonna face
cole sorcerer big spot here upstairs
ball four
bases loaded walk astros take a lead
jose altuve
with the rbi number 42 on the year
top of the order cedric mullins 3-2
lined over the glove of el tuve into
right field cedric mullins as a second
hit of the game
now ryan mount castle at the plate 2-2
pitch
right field here tucker back at the wall
it's gone ryan mount castle continues to
do damage with
two out and runners in scoring position
a two-run
shot to put the orioles back on top
three to two home run number 14 for ryan
nice power he just flies out i mean he's
got that kind of strength fast ball
middle of the plate
orioles with a 3-2 lead over the astros
bottom of the fifth inning
3-2 swing and a miss a darting splitter
below the knees and cole salsa has the
orioles first strikeout of the game
and the second out of the fifth inning
3-2 swaying and a miss
strike three another splitter this one
down and in and salsa strikes out
alvarez and correa who are two
very difficult batters to strike out
yeah
go back to their bullpen for blake
taylor bases loaded
one out top of the seventh for ryan
mckenna
one two to short that's one on to first
and he's safe so the organs get a run
rbi for mckenna bang bang play at first
but he beat it out
we mentioned mckenna's speed it was just
enough to beat the relay throw
another 3-2 pitch call
third strike taylor a big strikeout
strands a couple of runners
in the process though the orioles do
pick up a run and lead this game
four to two seventh inning baseball
astros down four to two
the orioles go to their bullpen with
jordan alvarez do up and they will bring
on
the lefty tanner scott scott o2 pitch
breaking ball strike three
and down goes alvarez for out number one
yeah he might have thought it was low
but it was definitely over the plate
3-0 count to correa inside almost hit
him with 97. the
bases will be loaded as carlos draws a
four pitch walk
held up pitch down low kyle tucker draws
a
great walk to force in a run three and
two
down and in ball four straw draws the
bases loaded walk
three consecutive walks and the astros
have tied the game at four
two-two strike
he stares at a fastball up and away from
the zone the second
out of the seventh comes from tyler
wells he sets down garcia
high heat and he got him how about tyler
wells he's pumped up
comes in gets back-to-back strikeouts to
end the inning has already stolen two
bases tonight
and he is at first base for austin hayes
[Applause]
fly ball left field it's deep way back
and
out of here orioles break the tie
a two-run shot off the bat of austin
hayes
and the birds jump out top six to four
seventh home run of the year and it's a
big one pedro severino stands in
after the mound visit left field that's
a fair ball into the corner
mount castle scores here comes mckenna
he's in and the orioles get two on a
double from pedro severino
four runs in the inning and they're up
eight to four
oh that's hit well aureus with a drive
way back
and it's off the wall thought he got it
out he
may have to settle for an rbi double as
severino scores
and guess what he got back up and he
kept the hit streak alive
the last opportunity here for carlos
correa to keep his streak alive oh one
that's inside and i think that got
correa maybe on the back leg
as carlos now has dropped the bat he's
got his hands on his knees on the grass
just to the right of the home plate dirt
area
four hour and two minutes into the game
and correa
down five in the bottom of the ninth hit
on the back leg around the knee
on the ground that will be through the
middle for a base hit toro will score
tucker's gonna head to third mile straw
with the astros first rbi hit of the
night
it's now 9-5 with two runners on
line drive base hit by garcia the astros
will get the tying run to the plate
robel drives in a run
it is now nine to six if the astros are
one swing away from tying this thing up
hits the ball deep to left field
playable though near the track
back there is mckenna tagging his straw
it's now a nine to seven game altuve
tried to pick on the first pitch
after a four pitch walk and hit a line
drive but he is out number two
so now it's up to michael brantley nine
to seven game
tying run on first base two outs in the
bottom of the ninth inning
popped him up they should do it mckenna
calling
makes the catch and the orioles
hang on and get a 9-7 win